how's Gomes when he spirited past so
many of you brothers have suggested this
game all the Bros in the comments
everyone everyone my mom called me
display and she's like why haven't you
played this game yet I'm serious I wish
I was joking I don't know I don't know
anything what the [ __ ] is this all I
know is that we're gonna play it and
it's gonna be 12 a.m. / tonight alright
sir this five nights I knew that cuz the
title just sayin these graphics reminds
me of like games from the 90s I don't
know what it is oh god what the [ __ ]
what is this oh that's that's nice what
it's calling me
I work in that office before so I don't
forgive it overwhelming
and don't worry about
fine thanks let's just focus okay the
animatronic characters here do get a bit
wonky at night but drivelling oh if I
were forced to sing those same stupid
songs for 20 years I never got about I
probably be a bit irritable at night too
so remember these characters hold a
special place in the hearts of children
we need to show them a little respect
right okay
so just be aware the characters do tend
to wander a bit they're left in some
kind of free roaming mode and drive
something about their servos locking up
they get turned off you are sure to walk
around from today - but then there was
the bite of 87 yeah it's amazing what
the human body can live without the
frontal lobe
if they happen to see you after hours
probably won't recognize you as a person
so most likely see you as a metal
endoskeleton without its costume ounce
SS against the rules here at braid
better right
forcefully stuff you inside a Freddy
fazbear suit oh nice
now that wouldn't be so bad if the suits
themselves weren't filled with
crossbeams wires and animatronic devices
but a first actually agrees I'm Jody
tomorrow
check those cameras and remember to
close the doors only if absolutely
necessary Oh
conserve power all right good night
oh god damn it I wasted a goddamn it
so whoa sorry out of order okay saman um
I'm a janitor a security guard guy and
I'm in a haunted Pizza reah good
surveillance thing and that's all I know
and I guess my job is to survive I don't
understand this is weird I can't really
do anything here I like what does it
like do what is it I don't want to
celebrate it's only 2:00 a.m. oh god
[ __ ] camera scare me come on are they
moving they're not moving so far what is
missing one is missing where oh hey
there little fella
hey doin a chat oh god where is it going
where did it go where the [ __ ] did it go
what the [ __ ] that is creepy oh it's
really close it's really close it yeah I
better close that door right uh oh god
it's still there what the [ __ ] is this
alright fine what do you want from me
I'm not a costume oh [ __ ] this job
alright it's flip burgers at McDonald's
in this I got goose nips like they're
exploding on my body lame what do you
want from me god it's so itchy
he gets goose buns when you got it's
itchy oh now he's gone where did he go
Oh what are you doing in the class they
come Chris get out of the closet what is
he doing I can hear them
this game is so weird oh god oh god he's
still okay he's out there now oh no he's
gone again what are you doing get out of
the closet what is he doing get a life
get a life oh god oh god oh god oh god
where did he go Jeff bloody feet dance
ballet what the [ __ ] oh my god are you
saying yes oh my god where do you go
what [ __ ] you [ __ ] off I only have 4%
lamb oh it became sex I am yeah that was
night one good job me
[ __ ] me Oh God now that [ __ ] again
how's my little friends doing I would
love to go to this pizza place the love
if I won my brain eating up Oh God
Thanks ah come on okay one of them moved
where did he go shut up
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
oh god I hate you how do you walk so
fast
[ __ ] you [ __ ] your couch come on oh my
god
alright so there's one of them missing
and he's there I'm gonna stare at you
I'm watching you [ __ ]
I can do this all day all day all night
kind of sick pizza place is this whoa
whoa what the [ __ ] is that what the [ __ ]
are you
is it more than no oh god no oh god no
not cool oh god oh god I'll get the
light just work they're all gone okay
he's still there
where's the bird there there's one where
the [ __ ] is the bird where is the bird
hello come on hello the Berber Berber
bird where the [ __ ] is the Berber Berber
oh hello that's a nice selfie you got
there
you look oh [ __ ] me not on my watch
oh hey mister bed let's eat
you can eat one everyone but not me that
those are hey there you look like a
[ __ ] perv
Oh God where the chicken go oh that is
some creepy [ __ ] man you cannot come in
and eat here no you can't you [ __ ] go
home you're drunk stop go home oh oh oh
oh oh that's great I want to go home now
I'm pretty sure that whatever they
paying me here is not worth it Oh j6 oh
come on okay don't want to do that again
maybe if we didn't have the fan on we'd
save some energy well I'm just saying Oh
God two is missing now where where
ha Oh God
I got to make it through night - if the
last thing I'll ever do
okay there's two missing there's one I
don't know where the chicken is all
right
check-in chicken come here chicken happy
happy happy happy
oh how dandy it looks like Rudolph has
is getting Rudolph Rudolph what did I
tell you about going to campfire
backstage Rudolph thinks he's an artist
but he's not Rudolph go back go back to
the show stage run Rudolph Rudolph
why did Rudolph go where the fudge cake
is he oh oh god damn it
Rudolph weirdos don't [ __ ] with me
okay Rudolph is hiding in the closet I
don't know why but Rudolph likes to hide
in the closet
all right ah you're not allowed in here
Rudolph I keep telling you ah nope oh
god damn it it will size out Oh God
where are they oh god oh god oh god okay
okay we're good okay okay okay okay
oh god oh god oh god alright rudl is
there oh hey ole sir how are you doing
going out for a midnight snack well this
is the restroom you [ __ ] to [ __ ] go
to the right restaurant idiot you have
beautiful eyes also but seriously no
midnight selfies please
Oh God where is she Oh for the love of
dicks
oh so freaky
oh this games insane my nips are diamond
right now bro I'm sorry that's all I got
for today I'll give this another go if
you bros go ahead and leave a like it
really helps me out a lot for us and
thanks for hanging out with me today
I'll see you tomorrow
bro yes